mmm and
please bear with us for a moment while I
get our live stream started for our
LinkedIn audience
this will take
a few moments
because in a one-click world this is
something that still takes 10 clicks
eating
okay
just check one thing
okay uh I'm gonna go ahead with the
presentation and we'll hopefully get our
LinkedIn live audience
a moment
a little issue with the streaming key
so welcome to everyone my name is Stuart
Creek I'm a marketing manager here at
simply learn I'm here with Brad Gattis
PPC chair for simply learned and a
co-founder of analysis and he's going to
take us through
creating and testing Google ads
responsive search ad
[Music]
um
especially so
for people who are here on WebEx
and her questions for Brad and the Q a
panel and he will be able to get to
those when we get to the Q a
um also be looking at the chat so put
that in for all panelists
but if you want the question to be
answered for sure put it in the Q a if
you're watching on a streaming service
please put your questions into the
comments
and
we're going to start off with a poll
this poll
basically is to give us an orientation
for who's in our audience based on your
level of experience
and we also do a little check-in
question to see how people are doing
during this
pandemic
hopefully we're on the other side of the
pandemic now and hopefully we won't have
a big surge this winter
uh
I just want to see how people are
holding up with work from home and all
the other changes in the world
and we'll keep the question open for
about 10 seconds longer
very cool so
here is the pull response
and Brad you can see it's a pretty even
distribution of experience
it's a little bit weighted towards
people who are either in school or
pressures but we have
a substantial number of folks with 10
years or more of experience in the
audience today and uh
very heartening to see that almost
everybody is doing well
so with that I'm going to
switch over and allow you to take
control of the presentation so I'll stop
sharing the screen here
I will give you screen control
let's go and there you go
okay let me add
let me go grab that
control panel so I can actually see
everything
okay
all right just to check you can see me
and you can see the presentation
everything is good
yes all right so everyone
I'm Brett Gettys I've been doing paid
search for uh
too many years this point in time I'm 24
um and you know I'm the chair and simply
learned for paid search and today we're
gonna talk about creating and testing
responsive search ads about six months
ago we did a webinar on how to CR the
transition from expanded text to ads to
rsas and since then we've learned more
we have even more data so we're going to
look through now how to create them what
we know today and then how to test them
because that's the next evolution of
rsas
but just to kind of get everyone to the
speed of how we got here right so we we
look at ads we think it just ads in
general right ads are really the
lifeblood of a paid search account it's
the only part of your account that a
user actually sees right Searchers don't
know your keywords your Search terms
your bids anything else right the ad is
that connection point it's actually one
of the most important parts of the
entire paid search accounts
and so we look back to when Google
launched which was 2002 is when you know
Google AdWords launched and it was text
ads with a single headline and two
descriptions
and this is what we had for 14 years so
most of the testing was done with
descriptions which weren't looked at
much you had one big bolded headline you
could do some testing with it but it was
one right and a couple descriptions and
then six years ago in 2016 Google
launched the expanded text sides or ETS
as we call them right they added a third
headline it really actually shows
anymore we'll talk a little bit later
that a second description more ad
extensions but then we had right several
years to really test etas now Google
launched rsa's initially in 2018. now
they were not they're mostly beta for a
couple years and it really was 2020 that
most people could use the rsas
in earlier this year right Google made
RSA the default ad format
now the thing with rsas which is so
different is it's all based on machine
learning right you give Google assets
you say hey go learn stuff for us
etas are based upon marketer thought
right what do you think how do users
interact control every detail
and these are really far different on
the Spectrum right versus hey I get to
control what a user sees when I type in
this exact search term so I can make
sure that I'm promoting my goals for
Success I'm using calls to action
identify the consumer I can direct them
take action I can shape this exactly as
I want for that search term
then we have our essays which is hey
Google here's a bunch of headlines and
descriptions and you figure out the
usual ones and sometimes there's a
hybrid model which we're going to get to
with that
and so often what we're thinking about
is how do we take what we learned from
etas because what RSA is their end
format
as Google's trying to talk to my phone
and the end format of what rsas look
like to the user is the same as an ETA
it's you know a couple of headlines a
description maybe two descriptions then
add extensions so the end user right the
Searcher doesn't see a difference these
two ad formats right the difference
really comes on the marketing side of
what you're creating and then how the
user gets to see that end product
and so all rsas are hey Google here's a
bunch of headlines here's some
descriptions go mix and match stuff for
me
and when we look at how most people are
creating rsas which are here are you
know a bunch of random lines that
related to my keywords in the ad group
maybe there's some calls to action maybe
there's some benefit statements they put
them out there and they see their data
gets worse we we our our system has over
a billion ads in it we look at all kinds
of data different ways
and when we look across you know ad
groups have an ETA and an RSA in them
with at least X number of Impressions
and so forth
etas when in every metric possible and
and you look at this and you say then
why do we want rsas
well rsas are the new machine learning
model right and Google was machine
learning and often when Google launches
something new machine learning it takes
three to five years before it's really
good we look at CPA bidding which when
Google first launched it the first
couple years it was really bad
now you don't even think twice before
you turn on CPA bidding for a new
account hey Google I want 20 CPAs go go
make the math happen and they're really
good at it now
in in so often in this whole world of
machine learning
the humans still know what's going on
right you're you're the marketer you
understand context you understand how to
connect with people machines don't
really know how to talk to people right
they're math based
and so we look at why rsas are so
inconsistent it's because a machine
doesn't know how to construct an ad
based upon the user context machines
construct ads based upon what they think
may be good or how other people wrote
them and then use math to decide right
hey this combination is doing better so
we should use that more often so what
happens if you've got you know rsas and
your assets are you know five launch
we'll Edge the ad group five benefits
maybe five calls to action
you'll have some ads that are just three
calls to action as headlines you'll have
some ads that maybe have a couple
benefits and headline threes related to
the ad group you'll have others that are
a benefit and CTA never talk to the user
and why they searched
right we often think our first step of
an ad is someone says Hey I want this
and you're right says hey come look at
me I have this
right that's that related to ad group
line
and and so the machine's got to go and
figure out what if I do three lines what
if I do two lines two is way more common
by the way and what should I show
now we know from years of data years and
years of data right that what works
really well in an ad is headline one
saying related to the ad groups keywords
we know what you want let's Echo the
user statements right with some other
contexts around it headline two a
benefit or call to action headline three
it doesn't always show so maybe we
support headline two or put an authority
statement in there
right so we know this works
humans know this the machine has to
learn this because it doesn't know
that's a call to action isn't no this is
a 40 statement and so that's one of the
biggest problems is machines have to
learn this which is fine
the the second biggest problem is in the
creation of the rsas where someone will
put in 10 lines related to the ad group
a single call to action and a single
benefit statement
okay that's 12 lines there's a couple
thousand combinations possible there so
the machine has to go through many
combinations to realize oh that single
benefit and single com and single CTA I
should show more often but it's going to
have a whole lot of random looking ads
to get that far
so that consistency which we'll we'll
get into later
um on creation of the assets themselves
is important I'm going to use the word
asset that's what Google calls it it's
just the headlines you give them
now step problem two with the rsas is
that someone will use the same RSA in
every agripendic campaign because
Google's story is
gave us a bunch of lines we'll look at
what the user searched for we'll look at
all of our data behind the scenes and
we'll just make these ads that work
great for you every time
now if you're using the same ad in every
ad group then you're probably not really
thinking about the user search for these
sets of terms we should show these types
of ads right and that gives us to our
third reason that rsas often fail and
again this is not a Google problem
um it's a Google messaging problem of
how they how the story of rsas it's the
ad group creation
so because Google sort of said hey give
us your keywords and your assets and
we'll make this happen
you'll see ad groups now where the
keywords are
NYC dog friendly hotel downtown NYC
Hotel Times Square Hotel hotels near
Javits all right and they the user's
like okay so I've got a keyword that
says NYC dog friendly hotel I'll make
sure my assets says dog friendly hotel
and I have Times Square hotels so I'll
make sure that you know I have an asset
that also says Times Square and of
course I want to call to action so I add
book now I want something fun so let's
say you know Find Your Dream hotel or
enjoy staying in New York City and I'm
done
now the problem here is that someone can
search New York dog friendly hotel
and the ad says find hotels near Javits
Center
where someone searches for hotels near
Java Center and they've seen that that
says dog friendly hotel
right Google is not really matching up
the keywords and the assets individually
and how they're doing this creation
and so in fact in this ad group
the by far highest impression word was
New York friendly New York City dog
friendly hotel my father honest
impression award
the assets with the most impressions of
what Google's making ads for or Times
Square hotel and hotels near Javits
mismatch
just by taking these keywords and making
these into four ad groups
and then supporting up those RSA assets
to be a little more
um friendly to the keywords in those ad
groups this single ad group saw rate 200
increase in conversion rates increase in
click-through rate
just by making more granular ad groups
and so this is something that years ago
for all of you been here 10 years right
you heard granular ad groups granular ad
groups you've heard this for years
but the story recently has been hey you
don't need all these granular ad groups
now we're not talking about segmenting
Aggregates by match types and all these
things you don't need to do that
but when you think of these sets of
keywords are related to these sets of
assets
if I have a keyword that is not related
to all the Assets in my ad it should be
a different ad group that is really
still a very important part of
organization
so next right we think about where's the
user in the funnel because you're going
to write ads differently for someone who
doesn't know about you an awareness
interest versus they're in the bi phase
so we look at where they're on the
funnel and then we think about our
features and benefits right features
true facts full point lists about a
product
benefits what you get out of it right
pretty pretty simple marketing
statements
now when we think about the funnel
though should we focus more on the
benefits versus the features goes back
to our keywords and where they sit in
the funnel so this is an important part
of thinking through in your assets so do
you focus on benefits or features and
you could use Authority statements and
so forth too
Sam a call to action
again most calls to action on the web
are terrible it's subscribe now shop now
buy Now find your product blah blah blah
right and and you've seen all these so
many times you just ignore them these
days
so changing up your calls to action just
a little bit can make a big difference
it stands out so much more but it's not
always about the call to action itself
right it's it's also about where's the
user in the funnel versus by now
if someone's ready to buy this day like
someone's like lowest price on product
number part right they're they're ready
to buy this moment right you want to say
we had lowest price in here buy buy this
right now
what you don't want to say is hey learn
more about this product when they're at
that buy face right you want to connect
these together
so when we look at you know what is the
percentage of conversion per impression
winning ads by the ETA layout because
etas we know all the stats by layout
rsas Google doesn't give you this data
right we can easily tell that mixing
calls to action and benefits along with
a line that says we're related to your
keywords by far the most powerful mixing
ctan feature second most powerful
so when we think about our asset
creation
often we're thinking about is we want
two maybe three headlines related to the
ad group The keywords in the ad group we
want to again if you're making three for
ad group make three calls to action and
then three USP or authority statements
then a few benefit statements we want to
mix and match these so that we have a
consistent usage of what's related to ad
group calls to action Authority and
benefits so that way the machine even
it's randomly grabbing lines to
initially test is going to get something
a bit more consistent in its usage
Touch of math so we think about how many
combinations these rsas could be so
Google generally displays two headlines
they sometimes display three headlines
so if you make 15 RSA headlines and
Google is showing two headlines you have
210 combinations
if they're showing three headlines you
have 2700 combinations
if you're now bringing the descriptions
into play and you say all right so how
often is Google show 15 headlines and or
sorry show three headlines and two
descriptions and then we've got our they
showed three headlines in one
description
if with 15 headlines and two
descriptions there are four descriptions
there are 47
000 possible combinations
now let's sing with that 47 000
combinations if you give Google all
their assets
so if your ad group gets 1 000
Impressions a month
after 47 months almost four years
each combination could have one
impression
now when they want ad testing right and
that's we're going to get into we said
we want at least a hundred Impressions
to do ad testing now granted you should
have more physically significance but
let's just say we want a hundred
that means in 4 700 years from now
all our combinations would have 100
Impressions now of course the Google
can't serve this way they know they
can't so they're never going to serve
all 47 000 combinations they're going to
serve a few start looking at what seems
to get better click the rates and maybe
conversion rates and lean more towards
those and not show most recommodations
we we see people who have more than a
million impressions a month and they
still less than 100 combinations so this
is what's possible
but Google knows that hey we can't
actually do this because no one's going
to look at their ad for now therefore we
need to make some guesses so you have a
machine making guesses on how humans
interact with
with advertising right which can
sometimes be problematic
so then
if you have ad groups that are getting
30 and 40 000 Impressions a month right
Google generally does a good job after a
few months but more often than not they
do when you have ad groups with a few
hundred Impressions or only a few
thousand Impressions a month
what you generally see are are things
like this where you've got an ad that is
by far the winner and every single
metric or top ad here
and it's been shown 1400 times in the
past month
we have another ad that's kind of in the
middle of everything it's been shown
four times as often
so what it's really common to see when
you have ad groups with you know 10 to
15 000 or less Impressions per month is
that what you often consider the best at
is not what gets displayed the most
so we need to fix this right I mean in
the end marketers okay is how Google
does it but we need to fix this for
ourselves because we can't always rely
on machine learning to learn all this
for us right now
will the machine learning get better at
context and putting things together
absolutely will it be this year I mean
that's two months left no will it be
next year a little better but it might
be a few years still like most machine
learning algorithms
so where the human comes in right is
saying Okay Google we're going to use
your responsible search ads we don't
have a choice
but we can we can reduce
the combinations possible and we can put
things in a better context sorry my
phone wants to keep Google on my phone
keeps wanting to talk to me
um
and so our goal here right is to say
let's use machine learning let's use our
brain because we'll think about our
combination pinning comes into play
with pinning you can tell Google I've
got these lines and I want them to show
in position one or position two or three
now you can have one line pin to
position meaning when this ad is served
this line This asset will always be in
this position you could pin four lines
to a single position
in that case you're telling Google hey
you can put any line in this position
you want to of these four you can rotate
through these four
so if we have three lines pinned at the
ad group we have three lines pinned to
headline two maybe calls to action we
have three lines pinned to our headline
three for Authority statements right
there's 27 combinations possible here if
three headlines are displayed but so
we're letting Google learn within our
human created framework
so this is how these combinations get
changed if you have 15 headlines and
this is the Assumption Google's I want
to show two headlines
which is by far the most common if if we
have 15 headlines two combinations show
no pinning right that's 210 combinations
if we pin one line that becomes 14
combinations now if we pin two lines
right to that particular position we're
doubling these so we could easily get
into you know two or three lines to each
of these lines but the math goes from
you know 47 000 combinations to a couple
hundred right and so this is a way you
can use both machine learning
and the way the humans have learned hey
this works over time
um to create these ads now as you do
this you're going to see your ad
strength plummet
and add strength is Google's metric that
says how great your RSA is now all the
ad strength really does is tell Google
how much control does Google get the
less control Google gets the lower your
ad strength is
ad shrink does not affect quality score
your bid your CPC your conversion rate
right all ad string does is tell Google
how much they get to play and if you
take too much control Google says it's
bad so you give them more ad servant
control
so for instance if we say we've got ad
groups with two R states with different
ad strings
oddly enough the lower ad strength
often has a higher CTR and a higher
conversion rate
because the human took some more control
and they're usually better than machine
now what ad strength does is if you have
two rsas in an ad group you can only
have three maximum if you have two rsas
in an ad group and they have different
ad strings
the higher ad strength ad generally gets
more Impressions because Google gets to
play more they like to control therefore
they will serve it more often doesn't
affect anything else
so don't be afraid to pin if your reps
tell you hey pinning lowers add strength
your answer should be it doesn't matter
if we get better conversion rates we
don't really care about ad strength it
doesn't affect our account in any single
way
so when thinking about pinning right
well we could pinch worthy lines to H1
for for and relevance and just have a
little bit of pen let Google play at the
rest we can pin two to three lines to
every headline
we could say we want to create themes
we've got add one with discounts we're
going to pin two or three lines to
headline two with discounts and let
Google create the rest we'll take
another RSA we'll pay um you know return
policies or something and a different
one and we're just testing should we
focus on the discounts the prices the
return policies the free shipping what
matters more in our headline to theme
right
or you could complete you know if you
have a lot of legal and brand you're
often going to pin a single line to H2
or H3 that's the tagline of Brands
um especially if they're trying to
coordinate TV commercials with search
ads
so if you're creating completely
unpinned ads you're like yeah we're like
Google play a lot of traffic
then you want to be consistent and
you're just in how you create your
assets right two or three have a bunch
of value that I group two and if three
have eventually that creation
and that's how we get our first step of
creating these relevant ads Second Step
hey we gotta test them
so when think about testing
we have two types of testing
we have a b or ABC testing
um often we just call this single Eye
Group testing where we're looking for
the best ad in an ad Group whatever
metrics you want to test by right and
and the reason we need to do testing is
in this particular ad group they did so
much traffic on the side group Google
should figure it out
if you look at impressions
the ad group with the highest CTR
is served more than 10 times x is about
12 times more than the other ads the ad
group was by far the best conversion
rate in fact it's double the conversion
rate of the ads for the most right is
barely served and this is where
looking at at your metrics and saying
wow if we were to pause this ad Google
really favors our ad group is going to
get a lot more conversions
and in fact if they were to pause the
worst ad group here the worst ad in this
case they would get you know two more
than 200 new conversions per month
and so the machine even though they're
going to optimize their ad serving
has a tendency to favor click-through
rate even over other metrics by the way
this is EPA ad group means Target cost
per action ad group so and their cost
per action is lower than what the top
ads actually getting for them and so
this is why even if you're going to let
Google have a lot of control you need to
know to hit the pause button when the
system goes off the rails so that you're
getting more conversions in the end
now the other way of doing ad testing is
what we call multi-ad group testing
where we're testing a theme a line an
idea across a lot of AD groups at once
and and the advantage here is we're not
finding the best ad for a targeting
method keywords audience is what not and
a single ad group we're getting more
consumer insights right these are the
bigger questions like should my
non-brand keywords have brand in the ads
should I should I use geographies on my
headlines
um should I use keyword insertion or not
or what happens if we use add
customizers for just one place but
across the whole campaign or even
account and it lets you really learn
from your data and so you can do these
as well with labels which we'll talk
about in a moment
um to get that bigger picture learning
so we look at
the most common ways to test responsive
search ads right most common is themes
where someone's got one ad in an ad
group it's focused on discounts loyalty
Authority What Not Another at the ad
group often focused on prices usp's
benefits and then they're going to take
the headline twos generally headline two
but if your testing geographies could be
headlight one mlpn between and then
start to see which ad is doing better
based upon that
another one is just to say hey if we
were to take full control right versus
we give Google full control what happens
and so this is where you usually have
one ad completely unpinned assets let's
just give it all to Google second ad
you're pinning again all three and and
so you're sort of that jump starting
machine learning
because add one will have a higher ad
strength add one will get more
Impressions you can still reach
statistical significance more control
what does better
now the the third testing that sets
right we're saying hey here's all the
stuff go play with it but then you get a
report in Google called top combinations
it shows you which way
um when the ads will show to users how
many Impressions each combination got
and often you'll see one combination
gets by far the most Impressions
um if one two and three and four and
five are getting roughly equal Google is
still trying to learn stuff they they
don't have a good idea because over time
one really does have a combination take
that make another RSA pin every line so
now you're testing all the options
Google has and at the most so why what's
the metric difference between the two
and and it's really common among legal
companies regulated companies
um public companies larger larger
companies to do fully Pandora says they
actually don't use RSA at all
um they'd say here this this is rsa1 and
often do
[Music]
um one-line pin-days position sometimes
I can add a couple lines one or two
lines but never position and they're
essentially recreating
etas in an RSA environment because with
rsas you didn't lose anything a lot of
people were like ah Google took our etas
away we can't do our ETA management
anymore
well yes you can if you make an RSA and
you pen headline one two and three and
description one you've remade an ETA
there's no difference between a fully
pinned RSA and an ETA
and so we see a lot of companies who
just they've tested legal and brand red
tape to deal with they just make etas
out of the rsas and you can fully do
that testing like you've done for years
so you know if you do in Impressions you
know we see if you get between 30 to 50
000 Impressions a month in an ad group
and you have one RSA
after about three months Google does a
pretty good job in in figuring out what
combination to show to what user they're
pretty good at that level
as soon as you add two unpinned rsas
into that group that number goes up to
you need a few hundred thousand
um Impressions per month for Google to
start getting a good idea of what works
which you know a lot of advertisers have
that traffic in a few ad groups often
not in all their ad groups
yeah so second is we have our unpanned
right so our add to here no pins at all
versus our pins line and this is how we
do that verify testing we're really
seeing
what's a better combination right
Google's machine learning versus the
human who said we're going to make this
ad and we're going to you know regulate
Google to showing you know these two
lines and headline two these two lines
and headline one
um so forth so is our overall creation
better or is Google's just complete you
know control better every once in a
while Google wins right it's not it's
not a advertisers always win I mean the
machine sometimes really gets it right
they just at low improv humans with
their prior knowledge and understanding
of other humans generally beat machines
at lower Impressions your gut instincts
pretty good
um in from a starting place and then you
get your fully painted versus fully
pinned now these could be
one add is just all penned headlines one
of each right essentially recreating
etas another one could be two lines
pinned to one two lines pin to two two
lines been to three and you just give a
little more control
um and so this is much more of that we
need control we want to do more old
school testing which old school isn't
always bad right a lot of you see this
really common among the larger public
Enterprise companies
the the a good common place to start
though is themes
where you're really saying you got our
headlines related to ad group we want to
make sure those shows so it's okay to
pin those in position one if you want
but we're really focus on here is our
headline twos
got some theme we're testing uh
geographies versus over a hundred
thousand served in a second ad or a
price versus a discount or you know what
if we do a you know buy two get one free
versus you know X you know sales coming
and so with this type of a test right
which is a pretty common test
initially this would be set up for
you're doing single accurate testing
you're you're seeing for the targeting
method keywords audiences whatever's in
the ad group right which ad is best
now if we want to learn this for a whole
group right a lot of different ad groups
across the campaign
then we get this in a bunch of AD groups
where every ad group has had lines right
under the ad group based upon that
individual RSA so it'll all be different
our headline twos they're going to be
the same in all these ad groups so we
might have two lines with geographies
pinned under a thousand whatever ad
groups we stay in the ad group two lines
spin the headline two testing some other
thing a price hours whatever
and then if we label them
we label the add one geography we label
add two you know whatever tasks and
you'll see in your account right you got
label label label
now you have ads right consistently
across the ad groups in a campaign there
could be multiple campaigns that have
those labels to them and the reason for
the labels is for the analysis
so be with pivot tables are a fantastic
thing and and I'm not sure I've done a
webinar and not mentioned pivot tables
at least once and so we can do is say
okay we've got you know these labels
we're testing across you know 100 a
thousand whatever ad groups
um we're consistent across all those so
we can download our data we can put in a
pivot table and we can see your
information by label to say in this
particular case right
um should we focus on the fact that
we're doing apprenticeships that we have
Master Craftsman on board that we got
technicians there in under 30 minutes
right which one does better and in this
case the master Craftsman did best but
that's where you can start to see right
larger picture utilized manner does
shipping matter you know so forth so
forth
so
if you need insights in an ad group
right or you've got really high traffic
ad groups or brand ad groups where you
know this is our brain message we have
to really look at how the the ads work
to Brand that's single ad group testing
multi-hi group is better for insights
across those segments
um you've got a lot of AD groups of very
little data so you don't get a chance to
test them because they don't have data
aggregating that data across that group
gives you more right so now you can do
some testing
um good for templated ad creation and
market research you know so things just
to really remember
in creating a responsive search ad
consistency of asset usage is really key
especially if you're not pinning
right so having you know two or three
lines related to the ad group two or
three calls to action two or three
benefits or authority statements
as you pin you can break this rule so if
you're pinning all your lines you could
have a single line pinned related to the
ad group now that means line one will
always be there you could then pin for
headline two it's inconsistent in your
your numbers of asset types but because
you've taken control and said well this
is related ad group it will always show
there you're still in that overall
formula of hey we understand what you
want right this is what you should do
next and this is why you should trust us
or believe or the the people to help you
out right which is what the ads really
doing
as you pin add strength will go go down
don't worry about it
um it does not affect anything in your
account that matters just affects
impressions in the ad group
so one thing about testing on our safes
right we want to learn I mean we test
because we want to learn stuff
pinning reduces possible combinations
right there's a big math difference of
we give Google everything and we have 47
000 possible combinations we we pin some
when we drop to 14 or 28. still a lot
right there's a lot of learning that can
happen in that but it's now a number
that even with lower Impressions the
machine can start to figure things out
because it has better data density right
with machine learning you need data
density is so important
um how much you know how many
conversions and clicks and Impressions
does each individual data point get
right the more it has right the better
it's going to learn from the math the
less everything has it can't find an
insight
and then if you're trying to find the
best ad for targeting method right
that's really what the single ad group
is for
and if you haven't done much testing
then single ad groups are good place to
start to
Multi Group is great we need to Consumer
insights but you need to be consistent
right that label consistency that line
consistency is very important so for
those of you who are newer you should
really start more on the single Eye
Group test those you've done this 10
years you should be very consistent when
you need to be
um you could do either that's based on
what you're you're trying to learn
right and with that I'm going to hand it
back to Stuart for a second for
certifications and then we'll get to our
our various questions
yeah I think Brad let's go to the
questions now okay and then I'll talk
about the certifications but uh perfect
a few questions and while you've got the
screen up maybe you'll be able to go
back uh you slides to illustrate if it's
appropriate but um
we had one philosophical question from
Isabelle it's the Google metrics aside
what metric do you really believe that's
one ad group apart from another this is
so ad groups in themselves are
self-contained units I wouldn't really
be saying an ad group metrics that's an
ad group apart from a different ad group
um when you get into testing or what add
what metrics you should look at to know
this ad is better than this ad
generally
um conversion per impression or Revenue
per impression which is is underused
metrics so conversion for impression
looks at how often an ad was served
versus how often it converts
which takes both conversion rate and
click the rate into account
simultaneously simple math right
conversion divided by Impressions
um if there's something I'm missing a
question feel free to
to you know put an update in there but I
don't think a metric sets an ad group
apart they're self-contained units of
their own data and the keywords are
gonna really change how each ad group
gets their their various data points
okay
um an interesting question from xiaomi
asks what would be the best way to test
a testimonial in America oh sure you
know the headlines to your theme test
right so here's here's rsa1 let's put a
testimonial or maybe two different
testimonials in our headline two pin
both those lines to headline two what I
want to test it against you know a price
or where the best or you know whatever
I'm just making some up here and let's
pin a couple of those to a second put
them out in the wild and and then do a
data comparison to see which one did
better
foreign
a question on the meta question on the
um nature of this
Master Class kynet asks will we have
better results with pinned him lives in
our campaign
you know so
it's actually not a straightforward
question answer if you are having most
your ad groups or a few thousand
Impressions 95 percent of time the
answer is yes
um you'll get better results with pin
headlines if if most of your eye groups
are you know a hundred thousand
oppressions then
Google will do a good job after three
four five months so the question becomes
it's after three or three months or so
usually so the opportunity cost right
you're going to live through this period
of time where you would be Google
and then over time Google either equals
you or or will you know surpass you but
you had to go through the rough patch
where you're telling the client Google's
still learning and some people you know
don't always want to do that or if
you're in-house maybe it doesn't matter
um in in general if you look at how
Google ends up showing the best comment
always end up with a combination which
is
at headlined ones related ad group
headline two is called action or benefit
there's a few exceptions but that's a
that's the most common way they end up
so generally just doing some pinning
jump starting the learning in that
framework you're still using machine
learning but and they'll probably end up
where you started but you got there much
faster
um
Ankit asks an interesting question so
sometimes in your examples you've got
oh so you're this is the let me just
illustrate this for everyone real fast
sure so if we if we look at this
particular example and we're focused on
its Impressions is the Google likes CTR
um and and part of the reason why they
like click-through rate is that
there's this assumption that if they
don't feel they have valid conversion
data if we get you more clicks you will
get more conversions right even though
it's not always true but it's an
assumption that hey if we're not sure
let's get in those clicks possible
because then you will end up more
conversions
and so Google's ad serving has always
been this way that they generally favor
click-through rate over metrics because
if they get you more clicks they'll get
more conversions so in this particular
example ad3 is a statistical winner in
click-through rate now it's not that
much higher than the others I mean it's
17.85 versus the lowest is 17.28
sometimes they're absurdness
and and Google the other thing with
machine learning right now
is it learns something and moves on and
it doesn't know when it should go back
to retest its previous assumptions
on this is really true around
um holiday season or if we look at covid
you know pre-lockdown post lockdown you
know in how things change so much it
doesn't know that hey the situation is
different I need to go learn again
because this changed right that's what
you're for the human is is the direction
so it's really common to see these
examples I mean this is not an unusual
example where the lowest conversion rate
has by far the most Impressions because
the way Google is that serving
um doesn't always happen this way but
it's it they're pretty easy to find
thank you
um
patish was curious to know what those
ads are but they're blurred out for a
reason I assume they are blurred out for
a reason this is in
most likely this is an insurance lead
generation
um which is why ad groups in a single
month that will spend half a million
dollars or a quarter million dollars
okay I get uh
for clarification yes does pending give
priority
all right so I'm not sure you meant
priority if you pin a line
Google will not serve an unpinned line
in that position so if I have an asset
one asset and I pin it position one it
will always show in position one it's
not a priority system it will only show
so if you pin two lines to position one
one of these two lines will always show
in position one your other 13 assets
will never show in those positions
foreign
thanks for that clarification so we had
a couple of people asking
uh about ad strength and just could you
reiterate your point about
um yeah add strength and pinning yep so
as you pin ads right well actually as
you create assets right so I'm gonna
actually I'm gonna grab this one real
fast anyway
maybe if I pull out let's see here oh I
went way too far way too far
so as you create these you're going to
see at the top of the screen a place
where Google is showing you if you look
at the top headline here your your
current ad strength which is anywhere
from poor to excellent and then what you
need to do to get a higher ad strength
usually it's add more lines or put your
keywords more often into the ad groups
occasionally it'll be like make your
your headlines more unique if they're
really similar to each other so you got
this initial part and generally if you
were to say we have 15 headlines
actually if you have 13 headlines plus
um and they're a little bit of a varied
you'll have an excellent amount of
strength
now as soon as you start pinning lines
you've taken control from Google
and and they don't like that so one of
your increased ad strength options
becomes pinless lines right so then
you're added strength drops and it is
really common to see massive accounts
where every RSA is a poor ad strength
because they pinned everything
um now this is just Google's suggestion
on what to do right now it in itself
doesn't matter it's Google suggestion on
how to improve your ads overall EF
you're completely unpinning things and
you want Google to have control
then you should go for a good excellent
ad string so they have a variety to work
with right the more you want to take
control because you're pinning or you
have legal or whatever restrictions the
West Side shrink matters to you so it's
a metric that personally I don't care
about at all
um I we I look at an occasion mostly to
see things like hey what happens you
know if you've got to as an aggregate
besides drink matter or you know why is
it that the lower ad strength ad
generally has better conversion rates
and click-through rates
um
and and so that's where you can start to
get this idea that restricting the
machine is not always a bad idea right
it's it's that right now we're in this
world of humans we have prior knowledge
we understand humans we have we
understand context we understand when
the world changes or environments change
machines work on
math
so you need to set up them up for
Success because they can do all this
stuff that you don't have to worry about
right but you've got to set them up for
success by saying this is the framework
the machine should work in and that's
what your job is as a marketer to say
well you can use machine learning within
a framework we devised and that
combination gets you the best results
usually
that that uh leads to Raj Kumar's
question which is is it important to
learn machine learning to understand the
the technology in order to be able to
take advantage of it this way absolutely
not
um you do not need to go get a degree in
machine learning to understand how to
use the technology and not at all and
and so the the biggest downside of
machine learning is even the people who
create them the algorithms
Can't Tell You Why the machine did
something all the time
and so the machine learns but it doesn't
give you insights and and that's the
downside of machine learning you'll get
some things that it will learn and you
can figure out why or or it'll tell you
why other times it doesn't so you as a
human looking over why the machine made
a decision or trying to figure out
um what's the difference here gives you
an Insight you can use other places and
that's why the business intelligence
part of this is completely separate
because machines don't only know why
they did something they just know what
the data told them to do
um we only have time for one or two more
questions so
um
Manish asks uh just a clarifying general
question what is the ad of dynamic
search what is the pardon me what is the
role you do not write headlines at all
eat the ads
then the user when someone searches and
their search term matches a part of your
website you told Google it was okay to
match them then Google dynamically
builds the headlines and shows that adds
to the user so dsas are Dynamic search
ads are created by matching Search terms
to aspects of your website as opposed to
you picking keywords there's no keywords
you choose here
it's a search from the website match
and I think uh the last question we can
actually take is uh
Rajiv
oh sorry I'm looking at a cautious
question
um
is there a rule of thumb for how many
ads are a good number in you have an ad
group you know what so with responsive
search ads you're limited to maximum of
three that's it you can only create
three
most people should not be creating three
um if you have you know three unpinned
ads that means there's more than a
hundred and twenty thousand possible
ways these ads can be served
if you are doing huge pending like
you're pinning every single line
then you could use three fully pinned
ads like you tested expanded text ads
you know previous to to July this year
um if you're doing like I'm going to
create you know some pinned ads I'm
going to pin two and three lines to have
unwanted two and so forth you generally
want to test only two just because the
way the math works out so you can have
data density to actually get results
okay
um
we had a question from Sanjay about how
uh Banning cookies will affect
remarketing but we just did a webinar on
remarketing uh for a while ago with you
right yeah we did our last webinar was
remarketing exactly so I I might ask
Sanjay to take a look at the simply
learn YouTube channel and see if you can
find that uh that webinar because that
might have some insights for you
um so with that I'm going to go ahead I
apologize for the folks questions we
couldn't answer
but we are running low on time so I'm
going to go ahead and
take back the stream control and move
forward
to the closing of our webinar
so let's do a quick poll
this quick poll is what skills are you
and the audience looking to add to your
digital marketing
toolkit
leave this open for about 30 seconds
you can pick one two three as many as
you like of that list
all right now we're just about there
here's the result
it's very interesting because it's a
pretty even distribution across all the
different skills
analytics and SEO EPC are the three top
answers I think social media as well
analytics Compares with everything
everyone should know basis analytics
regardless of what you go into not
selling everything but it's
data permeates everything yeah
and and basically what we've been
talking about today in this master class
this is the analytics having to do with
uh ad testing so
um as Brad mentioned earlier there are
certifications you can look at to add
these skills
um simply learning has several different
programs we have a digital marketing
Master's programs of two types one is 14
courses that go deeper into different
topics another one is five courses
that's a little less intensive but it
gives you a really good overview uh
still at that level
and
we also partner with the universities
like Purdue University so here's an
example of a program that we do
where as part of this program you get
master classes with meta you've got
master classes with Purdue faculty or
new instructors
and all of these programs are delivered
fully online
they include uh live virtual classes
with instructors like Brad who meet with
you weekly and take you through each
topic so that you're actually
interacting with the instructor asking
your questions you can turn to your
peers in the classroom in a virtual way
and
then you have a 24x7 platform to do the
work between classes so here's an
example of how this particular program
is built it starts with an orientation
session but it moves right into a
fundamental overview course of digital
marketing and SEO then a more intensive
course in pay-per-click the web
analytics as Brad said it's all
important it includes a social media
marketing module
and culminates with the Capstone where
you take all of those skills and put
them together into a digital marketing
program that you've designed to answer
an industry aligned question
such and such company is an airline that
seasonally so what is your plan for the
digital marketing program how do you
build that
that would be an example of a type of
problem that you would solve you take
several weeks with your instructor as a
mentor and create this project that you
can put into your portfolio and show off
as your experience in digital marketing
so this is a great way to build up
skills and experience and as I mentioned
you get the master classes with meta and
Purdue in this particular program
um and it exposes you to and makes you
actually use Hands-On a whole Suite of
different tools and platforms so that uh
when you add these things to your resume
you can legitimately claim that you have
used them and you're familiar with them
you know how to apply them to real world
problems so
I'm just going to ask simple final
question which is based on this
thumbnail sketch is this something that
you'd be interested in doing are you
interested in learning more about the
the simply learned digital marketing
programs
leave that open for 20 seconds or so
we have a number of different courses
the question popped up is this a paid
course yes these courses are paid uh
simply learned does have some basic
courses uh that are free to access
these particular programs are paid
programs that end up with a certificate
from either simpler or from our
University partner so
um they're very intensive and very
exhaustive
and
poor results
so more than half people are definitely
interested another third or maybe
interested
somewhat intrigued
so I will put into the
uh chat
the link to this course first I want to
put into a chat a
link for you to
we have an arena who's in the chat
already enrolled and this is and is
going well so that's a good endorsement
thank you
um
here is a link to a quick survey which
would like to ask you to
do
about our courses and then here is the
actual link to the
um
hold on a second found it
the actual link to the category page
which lists our various digital
marketing programs
that now is in the
chat window for you
so with that I'm going to say thank you
to Brad I will give you his LinkedIn
chat
e-whisper on
LinkedIn
thank you so much Brad for being here
today oh and thank you sir for hosting
us as always
I I find that by hosting um these
webinars I am learning
quite a lot by
the I'm getting a kind of a mini
education here but again uh our programs
that include instructors like Brad uh on
weekly classes live with the
the students take you into much more
detail and allow you to do direct
interaction so instead of a just a
um waiting to the end for a q a session
you get to actually ask those questions
live during the class so that's a great
thing and I'm going to um
invite everyone to connect with
simplylearn on our social media channels
Facebook and Twitter we're at simply
learn on LinkedIn look for simply learn
and we look forward to keeping in touch
with you and we hope we can welcome you
into the simply learned learn learning
community so thank you all for being
here
and that concludes our webinar for today